[Music]
when i was growing up
i was taught in american history books
that africa had no history
and neither did i that i was a savage
about whom the less said the better who
had been saved by europe
and brought to america
and of course i believed it
i didn't have much choice those are the
only books there were
those were the words of james baldwin in
1965 the historic simplification if not
outright exclusion of black history and
the black experience
from american history has been a
long-standing reality
with massive consequences a reality that
has perhaps prevented this nation from
facing
its darker truths even getting to this
point
of elevating black stories in february
was a long
battle black history month actually
started
as a week in 1926 historian carter g
woodson the second african-american to
receive a doctorate in the us after
w.e.b
du bois successfully campaigned for the
second week of february to be
negro history week it would start with
abraham lincoln's birthday on the 12th
and end on frederick douglass's on the
20th it would be a week public schools
would teach students about the
contributions of black people to the
world
pulling from works like woodson's
journal of negro history
and as you can expect it wasn't
initially met with enthusiasm
slowly in the decades that followed it
was adopted in cities across the country
following the events of the civil rights
movement and the rise of protests across
the country including those of students
demanding improvements to black studies
programs
kent state university in ohio in 1970
inaugurated black history month six
years later president gerald ford
officially recognized black history
month
at the national level urging americans
to seize the opportunity
to honor the too often neglected
accomplishments of black americans in
every area of endeavor
throughout our history he said we have
to remember what exactly the concept of
a black history month was fighting
against
captured and brought here through
slavery black people were stripped of
all their humanity
and history and that suppression and
humiliation
reinforced by revisionist versions of
history that taught children slavery
was not wrong and the white master was
kind
textbooks would frame slavery as an
economic necessity
the settlers found them so helpful that
others were brought in and slavery
became a part of history
history is written by the victor as the
saying goes and american history as it's
been written
and taught conveniently elevates and
erases
certain moments from it when barack
obama was elected in 2008 the president
and the first lady made it a point to
remind americans
the significance of having a black
family in the white house
now we gather to celebrate black history
month
and from our earliest days
uh black history has been american
history
[Applause]
we're the slaves who carried the
the stone to build this white house
the soldiers who fought for our nation's
independence
who fought to hold this union together
the obama's even invited then 106 year
old virginia mclaren
a daughter of sharecroppers to the white
house to celebrate black history month
just a year after that event it would be
donald j trump in the white house
celebrating black history a man who so
proudly hosted a rally last june in
tulsa
oklahoma on the anniversary of what's
been called the single worst incident of
racial violence in american history
the tulsa race massacre led by a white
mob that killed 300 black people and
decimated
black wall street as it was called
that's where he wanted to host a rally
and the thing is a lot of americans
probably learned about what happened at
tulsa
from a tv show rather than from high
school history
because that's how this country's past
has been written it will elevate for
example dr king's
love and non-violence while setting
aside his searing critiques of u.s
racism
and violence 2020 was the year that saw
the nation facing a reckoning again
with the killings of george floyd briana
taylor and ahmed
arboury among many others it also saw
works like the new york times 1619
project
being heavily discussed a 2019 project
that aims to reframe american history
through the lens of slavery
and the contributions of black americans
so trump
well he had enough he pushed back with a
patriotic education effort
to defend american history as he put it
critical race theory the 1619
project and the crusade against american
history
is toxic propaganda
ideological poison that if
not removed will dissolve the civic
bonds that
tie us together will destroy our country
and it wasn't just trump his secretary
of state a man who represented this
country abroad
said people who criticize america for
its history and legacy of slavery
don't recognize that america is
fundamentally good
just earlier this year he tweeted that
multiculturalism is not who america
is so then which one culture is it mike
i wonder this is why we need black
history and black history month to push
back
against a continuing whitewashing of
america's past
and present joining me to discuss this
is american philosopher
activist author academic recipient of
more than 20 honorary degrees
dr cornell west he's currently the
professor of the practice of public
philosophy at harvard
and is professor emeritus at princeton
uh dr west thanks so much for coming
back on the show
you said back in 2011 that black history
month is a celebration of
love in the face of catastrophic
circumstances
what did you mean when you said that he
said yes i love you abstract my brother
it's love of truth and the condition of
truth is to allow suffering to speak his
love of beauty
beauty has to respond to forms of terror
and trauma
as well as uh domination and its love of
goodness so that the black tradition
is in fact a modern tradition that
confronts catastrophe
criminality bulbarity and at its best it
dishes
out love warriors like martin luther
king jr freedom fighters like
sojourner truth it produces wounded
healers like aretha franklin
john coltrane and curtis mayfield
yeah and there's also a debate
around black history month isn't there
some say that black history
shouldn't be relegated to one month of
the year there was a famous clip i want
to play you from morgan freeman in a
2005 interview on this
with 60 minutes have a listen black
history month
you find ridiculous why
you're going to relegate my history to a
month oh come on what do you do with
yours
which month is white history month i
don't want a black history month
black history is american history what's
your response to freeman's argument
no brother morgan's got a point you see
that black history is human history
it's modern history it's american
history there's no doubt about that
but given the deep deep roots of white
supremacy in the founding of the united
states
there's got to be some space some time
in which we have a critical discussion
about the truth of america
about what forms of justice and
injustice have been operating
in america and so in that regard
uh when carter g woodson used my fellow
alpha brother he says hey
we need we need a week we need a month
fine but i mean
it's true that our our lives uh brother
magdy is so
intertwined see america is both a
precious experiment
in democracy but it's also an imperial
criminal enterprise so when the vantage
point of indigenous peoples from the
vantage point of enslaved
africans from the vantage point of
working peoples who were crushed by
bosses with no right to engage in
collective bargaining until 1936
when the vantage point of women who have
been degraded marginalized or gays and
left
those are crimes against humanity in
various forms
but it's also the best of america in
terms of a democratic experiment
and so we have to be able to keep our
eyes on both of those realities
and you know and i know you know this is
true for uh
for for various social experiments all
around the world it has the best
and it has a worse and the best of
america has always been democratic
possibility
the flourishing of individuality
tremendous
energies unleashed among ordinary people
but the worst has been these vicious
american crimes against people
but when you talk about telling the
truth i mean this is what you know
people say history we're going to tell
you the truth but of course
there is a deep argument over history
and how history is written and who it's
written by
you've written the book the radical king
that's meant to put the radical back
into martin luther king jr
there has been a rewriting i think it's
fair to say of mlk it's life
legacy and history hasn't there you talk
about a santa clausification
of mlk absolutely because as you know my
brother
martin king was talking about war and
militarism
he was talking about racism in all of
its forms
it could be it anti-arab anti-muslim
anti-palestinian anti-jewish
anti-catholic anti-white anti-black
anti-brown
he was talking about poverty but he also
was talking about a spiritual issue he's
talking about materialism
materialism is something that can cut so
deep and devour your soul that you end
up thinking
that you'd rather gain the whole world
and lose your soul
as an individual or as a nation so
martin always connected
the spiritual to the social the personal
to the political and the essential to
the economic
so that martin king is a holistic people
and of course he's also
a particular kind of christian so he's
concerned about what
love love dust this is what love looks
like
in public tenderness is what love feels
like in private
that's the martin king that we highlight
and of course he was a human being he
had his faults and formals too
like all of us did and so we need to
have a revolutionary patience in terms
of acknowledging we're always dealing
with human beings
that's true it could be gangsters like
white supremacists uh in charlottesville
you know or it can be our own parents
who are
wonderful human beings but have their
fault in enfoiables
but in the end but if we don't come to
terms with the catastrophes in our past
and present if we're in denial
chickens come home to rules brother they
come home
we saw that just about dinner
it's interesting what you say about
denial because i mean black history
month a lot of people
during this month will be talking about
mlk
but the problem is as you point out even
in black history month are we getting
the real mlk
um let's talk about another aspect of
the recent arguments over american
history
the new york times is 1619 project which
has won multiple awards but also upset a
lot of people it was created
to retell american history through the
lens of slavery and racial history it
won a pulitzer
it's gotten criticism from the right
it's also got some criticism from the
left
is the project more positive or negative
do you think as a whole
well it's much more positive there's no
doubt about that though i salute sister
hannah and the others uh
colleague muhammad and the others who
were part of it but we had to keep in
mind no
interpretation has a monopoly on truth
we're talking about truth capital t
but the truth is bigger than all of us
so the 1619 project was a corrective
because there's been a whole lot of
histories told that downplay black
humanity downplay the role
of black black movements the ways in
which black freedom movements have been
the level in the american democratic
loaf
you fight for black rights it spills
over the workers rights it spills over
the rights as a whole
it spills over the gay rights women's
rights it has a humanistic
effect and consequence even though it
begins on the chocolate side of town
so that i'm all with the uh the dialogue
the debate
but i don't think any one interpretation
has all of the truth
so i i believe that the 1619 project is
a very important
challenge but it must be corrected as
well
yeah this idea of having a monopoly on
the truth is a very important one that
we forget about when we talk about the
past there's also this sense when we
talk about history that
it's just a bunch of bygone stories
something we can kind of
maybe learn some lessons from maybe
entertain ourselves with
we sometimes forget that history builds
the present even our future even today
so many studies like one from harvard in
2007
that have found direct correlations
between slavery
150 years ago and inequality economic
inequality today going as far as saying
that when we see broad areas of
inequality in america today what we're
actually seeing
is the lingering stain of slavery we're
still very much
living in history absolutely oh no
there's always a
pastness operating in the present
and it has effects and consequences it
undergoes changes but it also has
continuity but you have to keep in mind
we talk about slavery to our present day
we also had a hundred years of
neo-slavery called american jim crow
of terrorism of lynching hardly any
civil rights
no social rights no individual liberties
of any substance
so that kneels slavery also has an
impact
take for example the social security act
progressive for white
excluded what agricultural labors and
domestic
maids well that happens to be the
majority of black people
why because you had southern elites
that's part of fdr's democratic party
that wanted to ensure these rights did
not apply to his gym
their jim crow south so you can see how
slavery and neo-slavery white supremacy
continued through even fdr and we salute
fdr
because he was progressing in many ways
but he didn't break the back of american
apartheid he didn't back the back of jim
crow at all
eleanor his wife called for that he was
strong
but he couldn't do it because he had
these you mentioned from the south of
his party
it was a very different democratic party
then you mentioned fdr his painting now
hangs in the oval office
above the mountain place joe biden is
calling fdr a role model a hero
inspiration
let's talk about biden so let's talk
about biden he's
talked about targeting racial injustice
he says it's one of his priorities he
said once he won the election
black people had his back he would have
the backs of black he would be there for
black people
whether it's on the subject of police
violence or racial inequity when it
comes to vaccinations climate change and
the intersectionality there
with discrimination even the white house
website now
mentions systemic racism that's on the
website
uh have you been surprised dr west at
how much he's pushed these ideas
into the national conversation in just
his first couple of weeks i know
you were a big critic of his what do you
make of him on this one
i applaud him i think he has a chance to
be like uh linda mains johnson the white
supremacists from jim crow texas who
actually pushed through significant
legislation
for black civil rights and for poor
people as a whole but as we know you
know biden's got to pass you know
he's he's he's got uh a tie to crimes
against humanity in terms of mass
incarceration and the crying bills and
bragging about it and calling the young
brothers
predators beyond the pill he's got a
connection in the crime of invasion and
occupation of iraq and over a million
presses iraq is dead
he's got the crime of the unleashing of
wall street greed and the repeal of
glass-steagall
he's got the crime of the israeli
occupation of precious palestinians
he's tied to these four but he can
change and
and so i'm giving him a chance i'm glad
what he's doing in yemen right now thank
god
that brother ro connor and brother
bernie sanders and others putting
pressure on him i'm glad he's pushing
the
the minimum wage so i'll give him a
chance but we have to
understand he's a human being too and i
think he's very decent
at the personal level but he's been tied
to crimes against humanity he's got to
be he's got to take accountability of
that
but we give him a chance and let's see
whether he can move forward what we
don't want
is a lot of symbolic talk about race
that just
reproduces the poverty reproduces the
militarism abroad
and bring in some black faces in high
places and act like this is a major
breakthrough
the measure of black progress is not
black middle-class representation and an
administration
i'm glad he has some but it's always a
question of whether they have integrity
courage vision and ready to fight if
they're well adjusted to their own
neo-liberal policy
they can be black all they want and this
the black mass is still
suffering that's the challenge that
biden has but that's how you keep
brother martin luther king jr's legacy
alive you see
it's a big legacy to keep alive and a
big challenge for the new president uh
dr cornell west will have to leave it
there thank you so much as ever
for your insights appreciate it thank
you
hi i'm mehdi hussein thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching